[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend heute hat sich die
europäische politische Gemeinschaft
getroffen auf Englisch und in kurz EPC
jetzt könnte man meinen es gibt schon
genug gesprächsformate aber frei nach
dem Motto reden hilft immer hat der
französische Präsident dieses im
vergangenen Jahr initiiert vor allen
Dingen um auch mit den Ländern Europas
zu sprechen die nicht in der EU sind und
so waren 47 Staats- und Regierungschefs
in die Republik Moldau eingeladen nicht
auf der Gästeliste Belarus und Russland
Moskau war darüber wenig begeistert
weniger wegen der nicht Einladung
sondern wegen des Ortes dadurch würde
man Moldau in den Krieg mit reinziehen
die Republik die seit 1991 unabhängig
von der Sowjetunion ist ist ein Land das
Russland zu destabilisieren versucht
während alle anderen nach Stabilität
suchen ultra und Julia recht
der moldauische Sicherheitschef ist ein
wenig nervös die Ankunft des gipfelstars
salensky verzögert sich die moldauische
Präsidentin wartet bereits sie kennt die
Angst von Russland bedroht zu werden die
Ukraine kämpft auch für Ihre Sicherheit
Ukraine
beschützt uns wir sind sehr dankbar
dafür beide Länder haben sich für die
Demokratie entschieden
der Tagungsort ist nur wenige Kilometer
entfernt von der ukrainischen Grenze ein
Blick auf den Flugradar zeigt die
angespannte Lage der Luftraum über
Moldau ist gesperrt nur die NATO
kontrolliert den Himmel fliegt
Patrouille für die Sicherheit des
Gipfels
silensky kommt für viele hier ein Held
die Ukraine liegt zwischen Russland und
Moldau und ist der letzte Schutz für
Moldau vor einem russischen Angriff
zuletzt die nutzt die Aufmerksamkeit des
Gipfels um mehr Luftabwehrsysteme zu
fördern
ich will mit unseren Partnern über eine
Koalition von luftabwehrsystemen reden
wie das System das ist meine neue
Initiative
Sando leistet Schwerstarbeit an diesem
Gipfeltag in der Hitze empfängt sie fast
50 regierungs-
der deutsche Kanzler setzt auf die
Symbolik dieses Gipfeltreffens das ist
auch Bekenntnis zu einer europäischen
friedens- und sicherheitsordnung die die
Unverletzlichkeit der Grenzen anerkennt
alles ringt sich um silensky der ist
mittendrin aber noch nicht dabei Länder
wie die Ukraine wollen klare Zusagen für
einen Beitritt in die EU der Macht der
Bilder muss Europa Taten folgen lassen
wir verteidigen die Werte Europas mit
unserem Blut aber wir haben immer noch
keine positive Antwort wann wir
EU-Mitglied werden können unsere
Hoffnung darf nicht zur Illusion
verkommen
auch sie will in die EU
kosovos-präsidentin Osmani ihr Land
bekämpft sich aber gerade mit dem
Nachbarn Serbien mit beiden
Regierungschefs trafen sich stolz und
macron das andere Gesicht des Kontinents
Europa als Krisenregion
danach ging es für Scholz weiter Treffen
mit selenski Deutschland hat bereits ein
Abwehrsystem geliefert ob es mehr wird
der Kanzler bleibt
was wir machen können wir im Prinzip
auch immer mehr machen wenn wir dazu
Gelegenheiten haben ein europa-gipfel
XXL nicht alles passt zusammen aber es
gab viel Solidarität mit den Ländern die
Moskau bedroht
von einem zum nächsten Treffen dem der
NATO-Außenminister in Oslo inklusive des
schwedischen dabei ist Schweden bzw
konnte Schweden dem Bündnis ja noch gar
nicht beitreten denn noch blockieren
Ungarn und die Türkei sehr zum Ärger der
anderen Mitglieder denn Schweden hat aus
deren Sicht alle Bedingungen erfüllt die
Hoffnung ist dennoch groß dass man sich
bis zum NATO-Gipfel im Juli auf einen
Beitritt verständigt ein anderer
Beitrittskandidat kann sich dagegen erst
einmal weniger Hoffnungen machen denn
auch wenn einige osteuropäische Länder
einen klaren Fahrplan für die Ukraine
wollen den wird es so schnell nicht
geben das hat heute die deutsche
Außenministerin noch mal klar gemacht
Florian neuhahn
ein letzter Gruß
dann legt die Bürger gesund ab ein
Dampfer der schon den ersten Weltkrieg
überstanden hat und heute Touristen
lockt das alte Kriegsschiff verlässt den
Hafen von Oslo wo die Außenminister der
NATO ein paar Meter weiter über einen
aktuellen Krieg beraten der auch heute
erschreckende Nachrichten bereithält
erst diese Nacht wurden Kinder in der
Ukraine getötet das ist eine wichtige
Erinnerung an uns alle das wie die
Ukraine militärisch stärker unterstützen
müssen
ein Stuhlkreis im Rathaus von Oslo keine
Tische keine Berater man will offen
sprechen auch über die langfristige
Frage wann wird die Ukraine Mitglied
dieses Clubs das grundsätzliche
versprechen sie aufzunehmen hat die NATO
schon vor langem gemacht 2008 in
Bukarest 15 Jahre später will die
Ukraine nicht länger warten und auch in
der Allianz drängeln längst nicht nur
Osteuropäer
selbst nach einem ukrainischen Sieg
selbst nach allem was wie der Ukraine
noch liefern werden wird eine Sache sehr
wichtig sein wir müssen Russland daran
hindern sich neu aufzustellen und dann
die Ukraine wieder anzugreifen
seit 1990 sind viele Staaten aus Mittel
und Osteuropa auf eigenen Wunsch der
NATO beigetreten und bald also die
Ukraine paradoxerweise rückt erst
Russlands Angriffskrieg die Ukraine so
nah an die NATO wie nie die deutsche
Regierung aber setzt eine Grenze
zugleich ist auch klar dass wir mitten
in einem Krieg nicht über eine neuere
Mitgliedschaft sprechen können klar
keine Aufnahme mitten im Krieg sonst
wäre die NATO sofort Kriegspartei doch
sich vorher einigen was am Tag eins
eines Waffenstillstands passiert das
will der Nato-Generalsekretär und
erwischt im ZDF-Interview deutsches
Skepsis beiseite
alle Mitgliedstaaten auch Deutschland
sind sich einig dass die Ukraine
Mitglied der NATO werden wird das haben
die Staats- und Regierungschefs auf dem
Gipfel im letzten Jahr in Madrid
bekräftigt also darum geht es nicht es
geht jetzt um den Weg bis zu diesem
Beitritt und wir müssen uns jetzt mit
diesem Weg für die Ukraine befassen
bevor die Ukraine dran ist muss
deutenberg sicher aber erst einmal um
einen anderen Kandidaten kümmern
Schweden dessen Außenminister darf zwar
in Oslo mit dabei sein doch der Beitritt
hängt immer noch am endgültigen ja aus
Ungarn und der Türkei in den nächsten
Tagen willst deutenberg in der
türkischen Hauptstadt Druck machen die
NATO soll wachsen kurzfristig und auf
lange Sicht
insbesondere die Außenminister der
baltischen Staaten die alle eine
geografische Nähe zu Russland haben
haben wieder auf einen Fahrplan für
einen Beitritt der Ukraine in die NATO
gedrängt und zu ihnen gehört auch der
Außenminister Litauens der mittlerweile
in Wismar ist wo sich die Außenminister
zum ostseer Treffen und damit einen
schönen guten Abend gabrielius
Landsbergs
Herr Minister andere Länder wie zum
Beispiel Deutschland wollen sich auf
keinen Zeitplan für einen Beitritt
festlegen und sagen auch die Frage
stellt sich aktuell gar nicht irren sich
der deutsche Kanzler und die deutsche
Außenministerin
vor 15 Jahren hat die nahto die Ukraine
schon zum Beitritt aufgefordert und
eingeladen erinnere mich an Bukarest
aber damals wurde nicht konkret
festgelegt wie man das machen wollte ich
bin ganz gewiss dass es jetzt höchste
Zeit ist diesen Fehler auszubügeln oder
einen klaren Zeitplan vorzulegen nicht
nur
dass wir sagen die treten vielleicht mal
bei in der Zukunft sondern wir müssen
darüber nachdenken dass wir keine
Sicherheit bringen können aber das nicht
nur sondern dass sie keine Unsicherheit
bringt ein Land mit viel Erfahrung gut
ausgerüstet gut
ausgebildet und sie haben die größte
Bedrohung bisher bereits besiegt für die
NATO wir müssen das wohl ein bisschen
anders sehen
und sie sprechen sich deshalb auch für
einen schnellen NATO-Beitritt aus die
Ukraine erfüllt aber ja diverse
Kriterien gar nicht funktionierende
Demokratie und Marktwirtschaft aber vor
allem auch die ungelöste territorialle
die Konflikte die es da gibt die ja auch
nach einem Ende des Krieges bleiben
könnten also mit welchem Recht sollte
ein NATO-Beitritt denn überhaupt
passieren
die Kriterien darüber kann man die Reden
die sie erwähnen ich bin eigentlich
überzeugt dass das was sie erwähnen für
die Zeit nach dem Kriege dass wir da
noch stolz sein werden auf das was die
Ukraine dem Bündnis und dem Kontinent
anzubieten hat wenn wir vom Zeitplan
reden dann müssen wir klar sehen Ukraine
die Ukraine mussten sie Krieg gewinnen
das da herrscht Einigkeit rund um den
NATO Tisch also das muss so kommen
haben Sie denn das Gefühl nach dem
Treffen heute dass sie sich da annähern
nicht auf die Frage bzw die Problematik
ob sondern wann der Eintritt passiert
mein Eindruck ist dass wir absehen dass
wir zu einer kohärenten Auffassung am
Tisch kommen
als es losging mit den Gesprächen mit
der Diskussion brauchten beide Seiten
eine ganz breite und ganz lange Brücke
zum Konsens aber jetzt kommen wir schon
allmählich in die Mitte wir reden
miteinander verstehen einander besser
die Argumente die wir vortragen werden
auf beiden Seiten gehört ich glaube auch
dass wir bis Vilnius nicht nur Einheit
werden sein können auf die wir immer so
stolz sind sondern auch praktische
Ergebnisse der NATO-Gipfel in ihrem Land
der im Juli stattfinden wird sie sind ja
grundsätzlich für einen sehr harten Kurs
gegen Russland was bedeutet das
eigentlich konkret was würden Sie machen
wenn Sie könnten oder dürften
das einzige Rezept für den Umgang mit
Russland sagt der Ukraine helfen den
Krieg zu gewinnen und da sollten wir
nicht nachlassen da sollten wir nicht
ängstlich sein da sollten wir alle Kraft
alle Stärke unsere gemeinsame mentale
Power die erheblich ist das Essen in die
Waagschale werfen damit die Ukraine die
Krieg gewinnen ein anderes Rezept gibt
es gar nicht wenn sie nach dem Umgang
mit Russland Fragen in Russland werden
die Russen sich um ihr Land kümmern da
bin ich ganz gewesen ob jetzt oder in
der Zukunft wir werden Dich dazu hören
aber dazu gehören können wir in der
Ukraine und ich bin sicher dass wir das
tun müssen dass wir können
vor ungefähr einem Jahr haben sie noch
zu einem Sturz gegen das Regime zu einem
regime change aufgerufen das heißt das
ist aber jetzt für sie schon rote Linie
geworden
Sturz des Regimes nie gefordert wir
haben gesagt wenn das Regime den Fuß in
den Nachbarstaaten setzt wie hier in die
Ukraine dann laufen sie die Gefahr dass
sie gestürzt werden denn ich bin ganz
gewiss dass die Menschen die Menschen
die das Regime unterstützen diese innere
Kreis dass die so ganz happy sind
angesichts der Ergebnisse des Krieges
bisher die schweren Sanktionen sie sind
diskreditiert sie sind regelrechte
Parias der internationalen Gemeinschaft
können nicht mehr so ohne weiteres ohne
weiteres Reisen also ich glaube da gibt
es intern jede Menge Druck und ja ich
würde schon annehmen dass es zu einem
Sturz ist verschieben führt aber das
liegt nicht bei uns und schon gar nicht
die Entscheidung die Russen werden sich
darum kümmern
vor einem Jahr klang das ein bisschen
wie eine Forderung aber lassen wir es an
der Stelle gut sein ihr Land Herr
Minister NATO und EU-Mitglied liegt
schauen wir uns das vielleicht ganz kurz
an zwischen der russischen Exklave
Kaliningrad und Belarus und 65 km liegen
zwischen diesen beiden Territorien auch
die Bundeswehr sichert diese Grenzlinie
ab wie realistisch ist es das Russland
sie da angreift und damit ja auch die
NATO
wieder gesehen
dass Russland vielleicht Probleme hat
bis in der Sackgasse aber sich immer
wieder aufbauen kann neu erfinden sie
haben jetzt mehr Streitkräfte als vor
dem Krieg in der Nähe der Ukraine
zu reparieren gibt beschaffen gib ihnen
fünf sechs sieben Jahre wenn sich
politisch nichts ändert in Russland wenn
sie nicht besiegt werden dann haben wir
ein ganz gefährliches Land vor der
Haustür und wir wohnen und leben
natürlich in der Nähe
ja sehr wenn auch Weißrussland
das nun ja sogar um taktische
Nuklearwaffen bittet auf seinem
Staatsgebiet gegen alle internationalen
Verpflichtungen das Umfeld ändert sich
und nicht zum Guten sie sagen es völlig
richtig auch die
Streitkräfte der Bundeswehr sind da wir
warten noch auf mehr wir haben auch hier
eine Übereinkunft mit dem Bundeskanzler
mit der Regierung es wird eine Brigade
deutsche
streifenkräfte gibt ihnen Litauen wenn
die Bedingungen stimmen und wir warten
sehnlich darauf wir müssen Signale
senden jeden Diktator in der Nähe
unserer Grenzen oder weiter weg wenn er
daran denken sollte muss er wissen dass
die NATO schnell und sehr dezidiert
antwortet
sagt der Außenminister Liter und vielen
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit und alles
Gute
und das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen aufgezeichnet Landsberger es hat
übrigens 1991 als Neunjähriger russische
Panzer durch die Hauptstadt seines
Landes rollen sehen im vergangenen Jahr
hat die Ukraine russische Panzer aus
ihrer Hauptstadt zurückdrängen können
die Luft Angriffe Luftangriffe gehen
aber trotzdem weiter
ja in der Nacht wurde Kiew erneut von
Russland mit Raketen angegriffen nach
offiziellen Angaben starben dabei
mindestens drei Menschen darunter auch
einen 9-jähriges Mädchen zwar seien die
Raketen abgefangen worden herabfallende
Trümmerteile hätten aber zu den Opfern
und zahlreichen Schäden geführt
unterdessen berichtet Russland
seinerseits dass die russische Grenze
Region Biel gorod von der Ukraine
angegriffen worden sei dabei soll es
Verletzte gegeben haben
noch immer steht kein Bundeshaushalt für
das kommende Jahr nun hat Finanzminister
Lindner den einzelnen Ministerien
konkrete kürzungsvorgaben geschickt also
mitgeteilt wie hoch ihre jeweiligen
Ausgaben maximal sein dürfen bis auf das
Verteidigungsministerium sollen alle
Ressorts sparen das Vorgehen sei mit
Bundeskanzler Scholz und Vizekanzler
Harbeck abgestimmt die Schuldenbremse
müssen eingehalten werden hieß es aus
dem Bundesfinanzministerium
das
US-Repräsentantenhaus hat den mühsam
ausgehandelten Kompromiss im
Schuldenstreit zugestimmt um einen
Zahlungsausfall der USA kurz vor knapp
abzuwenden in der Nacht stimmte eine
große Mehrheit der Abgeordneten dafür
dass die Schulden Obergrenze bis 2025
ausgesetzt wird zudem sollen die
staatlichen Ausgaben in den nächsten
zwei Jahren deutlich beschränkt werden
bis Montag muss noch der Senate über den
Gesetzentwurf abstimmen
deutschland ist einer Millionenstrafe
der EU-Kommission wegen nitratbelastetem
Grundwasser entgangen die Behörde hat
ein entsprechendes
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren heute
eingestellt nachdem das Bundeskabinett
gestern neue düngeregeln auf den Weg
gebracht hatte bereits 2018 war die
Bundesrepublik vom Europäischen
Gerichtshof verurteilt worden weil die
Regierung zu wenig gegen nitrate im
Grundwasser unternommen hatte
Hauptursache für das tödliche Zugunglück
von Garmisch-Partenkirchen vor einem
Jahr sollen nach derzeitigem
Ermittlungsstand beschädigte
Betonschwellen gewesen sein zu diesem
Ergebnis kommt ein Zwischenbericht der
Bundesstelle für Eisenbahn Unfall
Untersuchung vorsorglich will die Bahn
hunderttausende dieser Schwellen
austauschen Anfang Juni 2022 war ein
Regionalzug nach München entgleist fünf
Menschen starben 78 wurden verletzt die
Untersuchungen dauern noch an
es ist ein cs-ring aber es ist halt auch
ein großes Vorhaben die
krankenhausreform und wie bei allen
Dingen die verändert werden sollen gibt
es Vorbehalte Fragen Bedenken und auch
Interesse und so musste der
Gesundheitsminister heute feststellen
dass er mit einem seiner wichtigsten
Anliegen der Einteilung von
Krankenhäusern in Levels nicht
durchdringen wird dafür sind sich Bund
und Länder aber an anderer Stelle dann
doch näher gekommen Britta Spiekermann
rein optisch ist die Sache klar
Bundesminister Karl Lauterbach geht
voran ihm folgen drei
landesgesundheitsminister faktisch aber
ist es ganz anders
also vollkommen klar ist die Länder
haben den Hut auf in der
Krankenhausplanung
das ist unser Job genau das wollten die
Länder dem Bundesminister einmal gesagt
haben eigentlich sollten alle Kliniken
in drei Level in drei Versorgungsstufen
eingeteilt werden ganz oben die
Universitätsmedizin dann die
Fachkrankenhäuser und die Grundversorger
dieses Reform Herzstück von Lauterbach
ist vom Tisch bei aller Schmeichelei
wir brauchen eine Vertrauenskultur die
hat heute ein signifikanten Schub nach
vorne gemacht und das zweite ist bei den
Leveln werden wir keine Freunde da
werden da kommen wir nicht überein dafür
soll es bundeseinheitliche
Leistungsgruppen geben also Behandlungen
die Kliniken ausführen dürfen NRW ist
Vorbild und Lauterbach verspricht sich
mehr Transparenz und Vergleichbarkeit
man klickt auf die Klinik meintwegen
kniegelenksersatz und dann sieht man das
ist der Grünen hinterlegt dann weiß man
das wird dort angeboten und die Qualität
ist stimmig sie ist da dann ist das eine
Klinik wo man das machen kann da
bezahlen wir auch wer auf Dauer die
Qualität nicht bringt wird nicht mehr
bezahlt aber wer kontrolliert Klinik und
Qualität vieles ist offen einig ist man
sich schon länger dass die Abrechnung
rein nach Fallpauschalen so wie es jetzt
noch ist zurückgefahren wird es soll
einen Mix geben Ausfall und
vorhaltepauschalen die dafür bezahlt
werden das Kliniken schlicht
bereitstehen für PatientInnen und
verwenden doch in fast allen
reformfeldern gibt es noch
streitspielraum und natürlich ist es
kein Zufall dass der bayerische
Gesundheitsminister heute nicht mit
ampull steht ausgerechnet parallel macht
er sein eigenes Statement so sieht
Abgrenzung aus für mich ist es wichtig
dass die Menschen in den ländlichen
Räumen gut und qualitätsvoll versorgt
werden und Versorgung kein Privileg der
Metropole ist wie kann gewährleistet
werden und das kleine Kliniken auf dem
Land nicht zu kurz kommen häufig sind
diese im Angebot weit aufgestellt aber
eben wenig spezialisiert kommen
Versorgungszentren es bleibt ein wunder
Punkt laut Lauterbach muss jetzt alles
schnell gehen
sehr viele Krankenhäuser sind
existenziell jetzt bedroht können ohne
die Reform nicht klar kommen am Ende ist
es mit der anfänglichen Ordnung wieder
vorbei die Landesministerin und ihre
zwei Kollegen strömen zurück in die
Heimat Karl Lauterbach bleibt zurück die
Reform verlagert sich zunehmend von ihm
weg
was war das für ein Kassenschlager das 9
euro-ticket da hat man auch so halb gern
in Kauf genommen das Züge Verspätung
hatten auf einem anderen Gleis Einfuhren
oder ab und an gar nicht fuhren der
Preis war einfach unschlagbar dann wurde
lange darum gerungen wie es weitergeht
mit dem neuen euro-ticket technisch und
finanziell das Ergebnis ist das 49 Euro
Ticket das ist nun seit einem Monat gibt
und sowohl Freude wie Frust auslöst ein
Zwischenstand von Peter Theißen der
Einstieg ins deutschland-ticket ist
geschafft einen Monat lang haben
Millionen Deutsche nah und
Regionalverkehr für 49 € ausprobieren
können für den Urlaub ist es jetzt ganz
praktisch dass ich mir dann teilticket
kaufen musste wie viel z.B auch eine
Fernbeziehung es ist ganz praktisch dass
man da jetzt auf jeden Fall gut Geld
sparen kann es ist manchmal so voll dass
alle Leute stehen dass er eigentlich so
gut wie gar kein Platz mehr ist Kritik
gibt es daran dass man das Ticket nicht
am Automaten oder Schalter kaufen kann
sondern nur online und zwar als Abo das
Kündigen relativ aufwendig trotzdem der
Ansturm auf das deutschland-ticket ist
zwar nicht so groß wie letztes Jahr auf
die 9 Euro Variante doch bei der Bahn
freut man sich über bereits 10 Millionen
verkaufte Tickets und in 10 Millionen
sind 700.000 Fahrgäste die bislang noch
gar nicht Nahverkehr gefahren sind und
die jetzt neu dazugekommen sind und die
dann möglicherweise ihr eigenes Auto
jetzt stehen lassen allerdings manche
meinen das Versprechen einer
klimafreundlichen Verkehrswende für alle
das können die Bahn in ihrem jetzigen
Zustand gar nicht erfüllen die
Erweiterung der Züge des Personals und
auch der Ausbau der Strecken das muss
jetzt sehr schnell passieren den
eigentlich hat man mit diesem Ticket das
Pferd vom Schwanz heraufgezäumt man
hätte eigentlich erst die bessere
Infrastruktur haben müssen und dann das
Ticket anschaffen müssen dennoch dass
Deutschland Ticket könnte einen
wichtigen Beitrag zur Verkehrswende
leisten dafür bräuchte es aber vor allem
auf dem Land verlässliche Verbindungen
den sogenannten deutschlandtakt und der
Deutschland Takt als Zwilling des
deutschlandtickets muss so schnell wie
möglich eingeführt werden die
Bundesregierung steht da im Moment noch
auf der Bremse sobald wir auch im
ländlichen Raum ganz viele moderne
innovative Bussysteme einführen
ortsbusse Stadtbusse dann ist das
natürlich auch sehr relevant für die
Pendler die leider im ländlichen Raum im
Moment überwiegend im Auto sitzen zur
Zeit ist das deutschland-ticket vor
allem für Pendler in den Ballungsräumen
interessant und für Urlauber wer möchte
der kann diesen Sommer unschlagbar
günstig durch ganz Deutschland reisen
und wir machen jetzt weiter mit der
Wirtschaft Hanna und da geht es um
Schutz und Schmutz das EU-Parlament hat
heute für ein strenges
lieferkettengesetz gestimmt es sieht vor
das größere Firmen in der EU künftig
sicherstellen müssen dass es bei ihren
internationalen Lieferanten nicht etwa
zu Kinderarbeit oder auch zu
Umweltverschmutzung kommt und Valerie
Haller das Parlament hat die bisherigen
Pläne der EU-Kommission dabei noch
einmal deutlich verschärft inwiefern
genau ja das stimmt sie hat sie noch mal
verschärft und es geht sogar über das
deutsche lieferkettengesetz hinaus im
aktuellen Entwurf sind die Straßen
härter der Finanzsektor ist jetzt mit
eingeschlossen und Unternehmen müssen
auch Partnerfirmen überwachen die
zuständig sind für Verkauf Vertrieb
Transport Lagerung bis hin zur
Entsorgung der Produkte vor allem aber
soll das europäische lieferkettengesetz
auch schon bei kleineren Unternehmen
greifen die Vorschriften sollen für
folgende in der EU ansässige Unternehmen
gelten Firmen mit mehr als 250
Mitarbeitenden und einem weltweiten
Umsatz von über 40 Millionen Euro die
europäischen Richtlinien sind härter als
die Deutschen und vermutlich eine
Herausforderung vor allem für den
Mittelstand von Seiten der Wirtschaft
kommt Kritik aus welchen Gründen ja also
Wirtschaftsverbände sagen dass da sehr
viel Bürokratie auf die Unternehmen
zukommt die eben vor allem kleine und
mittlere Firmen überfordern könnte die
Industrie und Handelskammer spricht von
unkalkulierbarem Haftungsrisiko von
Unternehmen würde eine Kontrolle
erwartet die außerhalb ihrer eigenen
Einflussmöglichkeiten liegen also viel
Kritik am geplanten Gesetz dieses muss
allerdings noch mit den Mitgliedsländern
verhandelt werden und da wird sicher
noch heißt diskutiert über den ein oder
anderen Punkt vielen Dank Valerie für
diese Einordnungen
Tennisprofi Daniel Altmaier hat bei den
French Open in Paris überraschend die
dritte Runde erreicht der Weltranglisten
79 aus Kempten siegte gegen Top Ten
Spieler Jannik Sinner aus Italien in
fünf umkämpften Sätzen dagegen ist
Annalena Friedsam als letzte deutsche
Tennisspielerin ausgeschieden sie
unterlag der Russin Jekaterina Alexandra
die ZDF Journalistin Katrin Eigendorf
ist mit dem Walter lübcke-preis
ausgezeichnet worden die hessische
Landesregierung vergibt diesen in
Gedenken an den Kasseler
Regierungspräsidenten der heute vor
genau vier Jahren von einem
Rechtsextremisten ermordet wurde der
Preis würdigt Persönlichkeiten die sich
besonders für die Demokratie engagieren
Eigendorf Berichte oft unter Einsatz
ihres eigenen Lebens wie hier in der
Ukraine oder aus Afghanistan und
verschaffe Opfern von Krieg und
Vertreibung Gehör hieß es in der
Begründung der Jury
und wer jetzt mit Maybrit Illner und
ihrer Runde in den Heizungskeller will
der sollte dran bleiben unter der
Überschrift Druck auf dem Kessel Ampel
streitet Land verzweifelt
und später gegen 0:30 Uhr gibt es dann
hier unser heute journal Update mit
Kristina von Ungarn Berg und das war es
von uns wir sehen uns morgen wieder wenn
Sie wollen machen Sie es gut tschüss
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter
meteorologischer Sommeranfang heute
jetzt kommen die längsten Tage des
Jahres und dazu gab es auch viel Sonne
in der Mitte und im Süden des Landes im
Norden startete der Tag aber bewölkt im
Verlauf des Tages kam im Nordosten die
Sonne dann doch raus vor allem in
Niedersachsen blieb ist aber bewölkt und
das sorgte für große
Temperaturunterschiede 29 Grad im
Südwesten 13 Grad nur in Bremerhaven mit
einem frischen Wind fühlte sich das doch
eher herbstlich an was anderes zeigt uns
der satellitenfilm noch und zwar die
vielen Schauer und Gewitterwolken hier
rund um den Mittelmeerraum wenn wir uns
jetzt mal anschauen wie viel Regen in
Mitteleuropa bis Montag zusammenkommen
dann sehen wir dass es rund ums
Mittelmeer bis 80 Liter pro Quadratmeter
in diesen Schauern und Gewittern da
können auch Unwetter mit dabei sein bei
uns ist aber jetzt erstmal kein Regen in
Sicht trotzdem liegt im Moment eine
Kaltfront quer über Deutschland dessen
Wolken heute Nacht im Norden des Landes
sich noch mal ausbreiten im Süden bleibt
ist klar die Werte sinken auf 13 bis 4
Grad nur in den westlichen
Mittelgebirgen also nachts müssen wir
uns noch warm anziehen tagsüber gibt es
aber die t-shirt-temperaturen zwischen
20 und 26 Grad etwas kühler als heute
hinter dieser Kaltfront vor allem wieder
an den Küsten keine 20 Grad 16 bis 19
Grad dazu liegen die Wolken vor allem
zwischen dem Emsland und der Lausitz
sollte es daraus mal regnen lässt das
schnell wieder nach hier gibt es dann
aber morgen nur sechs bis zehn Stunden
Sonne ansonsten wieder viel Sonne
zwischen 12 und 15 Stunden und über das
Wochenende gibt es ebenfalls wieder viel
Sonne Wolken vor allem an der Nordsee
die Gewitter an dem Alpenrand werden
wahrscheinlicher und große
Temperaturunterschiede 15 bis 28 Grad
tschüss